Is there a brand in form of white willow bark for paid and by throat neck that you'd recommend? Well, we use the
um, we're inflated that I think has white willow bark in it.
There is a cytokwel from research nutritionals that I think has other,
it's named cytokwel for to quench cytokines, inflammatory cytokines,
they're making inferreds too. So decreasing inflammatory cytokines or inflammatory markers.
That I think has white willow bark and other things that we talk about,
the flavonoids that we talk about,
but clear inflame has that in there. And even our,
we don't, it doesn't have white willow bark, but our product called bam,
which is our, um, which we make, which I've made for originally created for a brain cancer patients
and our line patients, I call it bam, because it's called brain anti-inflammatory mix.
Not very clever of a name, but that's what it is. And we still call it bam,
it comes in a plastic bag. Um, and you can mix it in your smoothie.
The benefit of that is that you don't have the capsules and take utility capsules,
even a natural capsule form could not be great for a lot of people.